this episode is presented by verizon
there is only one best network
the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers yep there's actually something
you may not have seen coming in the
jungle cruise movie i'm as shocked as
you are
[Music]
you've seen the rock make a jungle movie
you've seen the rock make a movie where
he teams up with a new friend to recover
a shiny artifact but have you seen the
rock make a jungle movie where he teams
up with a new friend to recover a shiny
artifact
yes return the jewel to the jaguar's eye
[Music]
twice you're going to take me to ocado
now get ready for the third rock friend
plus jungle plus shiny artifact
retrieval adventure in
jungle cruise
the disneyland ride that's maybe five
percent actual ride and 95 corny jokes
is now an adventure movie that's maybe
five percent actual adventure and 95
corny jokes ma'am don't forget to
collect your baggage i'm only kidding
it's behind you from some of atlanta's
most exotic green screen locales comes a
boat trip cranned with more painfully
awkward banter than the entertainment
lineup on a budget carnival cruise where
the only thing tougher to escape than
the ancient curses are the endless
punchline adjacent arguments if i have
to bring you back dead it's 15 000. why
should i pay more dead dead i'd have to
carry you should give up you should give
up the guitar don't get it hold on come
on i got it
i don't go it's okay to be nervous it's
your first time i know
i've done this hundreds of times i don't
know how to take that phrase this is
special would you like me to give it a
wiggle yeah absolutely not i could pop
around the back and give it a one two no
we're good oh my god is that your idea
of a joke that is not funny correct
meed frank a riverboat captain inspired
by the hgnh in humphrey bogart's name
he's an actual colonizer
with more bad puns than our starring
section before this i used to work in an
orange juice factory but i got canned
couldn't concentrate
yeah they put the squeeze on me too
mommy can you please make him stop no
one can that can't stop chuckling to
himself all the time
[Laughter]
sure the rock does it and it's charming
but if i keep giggling to myself in the
produce section of trader joe's suddenly
it's concerning
watch as the rock really delivers on the
physicality
sort of nails the drama what will happen
to you
i get to make a choice
and i choose to rest and speaks the
tiniest amount of fourth grade spanish
so we know he's from the area
now this is a man who can tell me where
the bibliotheque is
but he finally gets to shine in a role
he was destined to play
an actual rock hope he didn't take the
opportunity for granite
do you think he was petrified before
this scene
or does he get enough stone cold sleep
often
when headstrong scientist rachel wise
from the mummy i mean lily houghton
hires frank for a trip down the river
the chemistry is undeniable between the
rock and his boat
[Music]
the rock and her gay brother had a
girlfriend once she was cross-eyed
didn't work out we could never see eye
to eye
the rock and his pet jaguar you're the
best cat i've ever had the rock and his
child servant
really anyone except the rock and lily
houghton
get off me what are you doing i'm trying
to get traction this is ridiculous just
leave me alone that was a disaster
you're too heavy still emily blunt
thrills as a woman with dual phds and
bodney and parkour nothing will stop her
from joining the he-man woman haters
club a tribe whose chief a lady
not even if that means stealing an
entire civilization's most prized
natural resource and using it
exclusively to help her new bestie with
benefits wow they really stick it to
that indigenous tribe the imagineers are
gonna have to shut this right down for
some re-tooling again
is the dark history of european
imperialism not fun enough for you then
climb aboard for supporting cast of
cutoffs featuring jack whitehall as
disney's eighth first live-action gay
character with a perfectly
self-contained coming out moment for
easy chinese sensor removal paul
giamatti as the guy from the pizza boxes
and the main villain princio
prince what
prince
jesse plimmons he's not exactly a nazi
but he's not exactly not see
he's like if warner herzog was a fascist
who took orders from a bee the arrow hit
the arrow hit yes show me show me where
well at least the movie doesn't feel the
need to point out that it's funny that
he's talking to him we're taking orders
from a bee hey movies please stop
pointing out the funny thing we get it
so if you like the first pirates of the
caribbean film disney's hoping it's
because you like movies where a boat
captain and a headstrong tomboy lady
clash and then they run across some
nasty europeans who are actually
immortal so the captain pretends to die
to save the others but he turns out to
be immortal too and the headstrong
tomboy lady ends up saving him in the
end savvy
[Music]
starring
steamboat silly
between a rock and his hard place
waken snake brotherhood of the traveling
pants
friday nine lights
it's sammy apollo giovati
a tribe called test
and contractually obligated reminders
that the rock is swole i wouldn't trust
you as far as i could throw you which
clearly isn't very far because you are
huge big strong boy gosh there's a lot
of you isn't there yeah there is
raiders of the lost bark
seriously it's great that this and hobbs
and shaw are finally ending the rock's
iconic run of never getting action in
his own action movies but can some high
school drama teacher step in and teach
him to stage kiss
you can do it put your back into it will
the real slim shady please stand up
my prickly toenails scratch my husband
at night
you